[Music]
what's up everybody this is lord sabre
from the iron lords podcast at
lordsofgaming.net coming to you live
from the show floor of taxis 2022
it is our great honor and pleasure to be
here
with the devs of tmnt shredders revenge
and the guys at tribute games so
we're talking to the writer here yeah hi
hi your name is uh my name is yannick
belzel i am the writer slash narrative
designer whatever they call it in the
industry uh on tmnt and
most tribute games yeah okay so tell us
a little bit about
as an old school fan when i saw this
coming back and i saw the work that you
guys had done previously with streets of
h4 i knew this was going to be a game
that i was going to absolutely love so
tell me what was the impetus for you
guys to go out and get
tmnt and bring it back to the first
world uh well first the thing is tribute
game is not uh responsible for uh
streets of rage but
dot mu is with another developer but
that was what
was really useful is that that imu had
all this modern beat em up expertise so
they really helped us out how to make a
modern uh beautiful because a lot of
people on our team worked on scott
pilgrim and they did uh the 2007 tmnt
movie adaptation on gameboy advance back
in the day so
uh stupid games is skilled into making
beat em ups but not more modern recent
videos so that's where i thought it
really helped as to why we uh wanted to
do the turnovers games uh attribute
games
pretty much every single games that we
did were
original creations but
uh we always said that if there's one
there are two things we can't say no to
and one of them is tmnt and the other
would be mega man so
um for a couple of years the company
like
circled around nickelodeon tried to get
it happen like
and they would pitch
other franchises to us but we said no
we want to do the tmnt uh preferably 87
tmnt
but
so
but it never really happened but dotted
you was also circling them and
eventually uh the people from that view
uh met with uh our uh leaders at tribal
games and uh they met up and eventually
they got together to sort of pitch
themselves to uh nickelodeon and we got
uh the extreme pleasure of making that
game so that's pretty much how it
happened yeah that's absolutely amazing
because again it was one of those things
it's very certain different it's just so
everything happens in in its perfect
time so tell me because as i was
watching and playing the game it is one
of those things where you look at the
game and the nostalgia comes rushing
back it does look like a very old-school
pixel art beautiful game how is it
modernized because i was saying the same
thing it's obviously when you look at
the old games it brings you back and it
makes you think that it's an old game
but it's not it has very modern
sensibilities so tell me in what way
does it have modern text abilities well
the main one is now the uh it's in
widescreen with
instead of being four three like you
know uh when it's four three the turtles
are taller like in the art of the arcade
game so the fact that it's widescreen
and also like all of the animators
worked on
the previous game were brilliant but
they have a whole lot of limitations
that we don't have we have more colors
we can have animations with more frames
and so that allows for the turtles to
have
to be more distinctive and also have
everyone have their own animations and
so part wise that's how we can uh
also because we don't have the
limitations like the backgrounds can be
this these lovingly like almost pixel
painted lush
environments instead of being tile sets
so that's how
and also again because we don't have the
same limitations we can also have like
unique enemy spawns like so the
characters can just like pop up uh from
a desk or part of the background at the
full circle attack so
we really have the technology to make
to add more to uh classic pixel art
styles which is something we do actually
games is that we always use like um
old-school mechanics but we have to we
we keep adding fresh modern techniques
absolutely that's exactly what i noticed
it's like when you look at it
nostalgia one plays kind of tricks on
your mind a little bit right because you
think hey it looked exactly like this
and the truth of the matter is that it
doesn't um
so if you can't explain to us a little
bit about what's going on on the screen
right now what characters being played
and
explain some of the like the technical
stuff the things that you were talking
about that are displayed here in
addition to how you sort of came up with
the story but this is your narrative
director so how you came up with the
story for this particular game and if
you took any inspiration
obviously from past turtles but like you
said you mentioned scott pilgrim and
other types of games what type of
uh literary sort of inspiration or or
narrative why
did you have uh well i'll tell you that
the biggest
inspiration
is
our jackie chan movies it is a huge
inspiration because and there's a
lineage with a turtle because golden
harvest but who used to produce all of
the jackie chan's movies in the 80s they
also produced their first yemeni movie
so that's why there's that cool martial
art stuck in it but
one of my of our bigger ideas is that
when you play the arcade game a lot of
the time the foot soldiers keep coming
and coming they just show up left to
right from the screen or they popped
from a door so
it was coming up with a lot of ideas so
the foot soldier would be part of the
background and would show up in a
comical way and always have different
versions of them popping up because
given that you're fighting them for the
whole game you're trying to
renew their entrance each time so it's
uh so
the game still feels fresh as you play
through it as for uh ideas for the story
well
the biggest inspiration is of course the
original cartoon uh the 87 cartoon but
that's more have to do with
the comedic tone and the the tone of the
universe so the rest of it is
because it's a beat-em-up story-wise
you realize that you won't have the
real estate for huge huge scenes or a
lot of dialogue so
uh i
wrote it like a long chase scene or a
long fight scene where uh bad guys are
getting away with uh thingamajigs that
build up to a doomsday plot and the
turtles are always running after them
but then another big inspiration was uh
classic simpsons the arcade game but
also the show because back in the day
when the simpsons first started having
all these funny details in the
background was uh
like it warped my brain to pay attention
to what i was seeing so we put a lot of
these backgrounds a lot of stuff in the
background for the game lots of easter
eggs or just funny stuff for the game
but also
when you play the uh the arcade game of
the simpsons at the beginning of the
level something happens there's
animation someone
has kidnapped maggie or something
so
it makes every level its own little
episode so that was our main idea to
like
uh
give more of that character flavor to uh
each and every level that's fantastic so
every episode has sort of its own art
and in in into the overarching story
exactly um yeah that's one thing i
noticed that the background
it tells the story right and and the
thing that you mentioned with the foot
soldiers absolutely happy because the
foot soldiers are sort of like the
minions of the game where they're like
the fodders and you have to make them
interesting in every single any every
single way whether different colors or
just the comedic tone overtones that
they have yeah so one of the big things
in this
this original game is that we now have
an additional playable character yes we
have master shredder which i absolutely
adore and april which looks super
amazing
what when did you guys decide in the
process we're going to add these extra
characters was it right at the beginning
or was it something that happened sort
of organically as we were making
uh very early on it's something that we
wanted to do with something that
you know like splinter doesn't
i mean
after the first couple of episodes of
the turtles barely fight anyways in the
cartoon but
splinter almost never fights so we
wanted to have splitters on this
character but we also wanted april
o'neil to be like
a kick-ass character in the game and
when it was time to designing a roof set
in our animations like we got really
excited because a lot of the character
comes from all our wonderful animators
who like make them but at the same time
would suggest things like one of my big
one was i want her to be to move like uh
cynthia rothwork in the yes madam yeah
and yes madam michelle yo
in fact
uh wears a yellow jumpsuit at one point
in that movie uh and i thought
this is how april should be i would post
videos of her from different movies like
that's how april should be like it's
gonna be like really kick-ass so um
that's
um how
there's that element of
i guess childhood wish like what would
splinter fighting look like but also
what would the april fighting look like
and uh
it's also awesome because
it sort of uh left
us a bit of liberty of creating moves
the turtles moves some of them are
homages to uh different things
uh some uh
from their moves from other games and
stuff like that so but with the newer
characters
quote unquote newer adventures uh we
could
sort of design their moves at the
beginning that was really exciting
yeah as a fan
i was super excited to see
these characters play and see how
beautifully they animate how beautiful
they play um and again the move sense
because you in your mind you always
imagine hey what kind of moves would
these characters have and to see them
brought to life in this game
with this amount of love and care
is is an absolute joy and pleasure to
see so thank you so much well thank you
thanks for coming um and i i can't wait
to see this game
so uh again
introduce yourself once again to the
crowd um and just let them know
more about the game when it's gonna come
out yeah uh so yeah i'm nick belzel i'm
the narrative uh designer at good games
uh tmnt shredders revenge is coming out
summer 2022 so that's pretty close uh
for for me it's almost uh right out the
door because we've been working on it
for so long wishlist now on steam
on steam uh write to your congressman
about it
uh uh talk about talk about it to your
mayor uh your clergyman whoever
we're looking forward i've been looking
at this game
see it throw and adding animations for
it and gameplay for it for two years i'm
super stoked to see
the fans
enjoy that lesson playing it like i was
watching you earlier uh looking at your
friend playing and i could see you
smiling under your mask i was like oh
that's that's what we're working for
that's that that's uh that's pretty good
that's why we come to
this is where we get to see these small
games come to life and again as someone
as a child of the 80s
these type of games are the ones that
speak to my heart and they are
absolutely you guys are doing such an
amazing job so once again we're here
with tribute games this is shredders
revenge coming out later this summer
this is lord sovereign for lords of
gaming.net and the ironworks podcast
you
[Music]